- [Narrator] Spacecraft tens
of billions of miles away
rely on this network of satellite dishes
to communicate with Earth,
but this system is in trouble.
The Deep Space Network
is operating at capacity
and can't keep up with increasing demand,
which experts say could lead
to loss of important scientific data,
like information about
the sun's magnetic field,
if nothing is done.
- The thought of not having
that constant connection
to our astronauts, to
these key science missions,
is a challenging and a concerning topic.
- [Narrator] Here's how
NASA's infrastructure
got to this critical stage
and what it'll take to fix it.
The Deep Space Network or
DSN uses radio frequencies
to send and receive data
like this image of the
Southern Ring Nebula
from the James Webb telescope,
or the sounds of dense plasma
(static crackling)
captured by the Voyager spacecraft
as it studies interstellar space.
The DSN also commands,
tracks, and monitors
the health and safety
of spacecraft like Juno,
which is studying Jupiter.
- What we do in space transfers
directly to the earth.
Think about the impact that
Apollo had on what we do today.
Camera systems, the technology
transfer into the industry.
There were certain fields
that didn't even exist before Apollo,
like software engineering.
- [Narrator] Because a
spacecraft's radio signals
are being transmitted from
billions of miles away,
they're incredibly faint by
the time they reach Earth.
That's why the DSN uses these
giant parabolic dish antennas
and ultra-sensitive receivers.
There's a total of 14 antennas
at three complexes around the world,
so spacecraft can reach the network
no matter where they are.
- Each complex has one 70-meter,
which is really, really large,
it's like most of a football field,
and then a series of 34-meter antennas.
- [Narrator] When data
leaves the spacecraft,
it travels back to an antenna
where it's decoded by the local facility,
then sent here to the space
flight operations facility
in Pasadena, California.
- Okay, copy.
- [Narrator] Where it's routed
to the appropriate mission control center.
But strain on the DSN has
been growing for years.
According to a July
Inspector General report,
demand is exceeding supply
by as much as 40% at times,
and studies show that
number will reach about 50%
by the 2030s.
Because of this, the DSN has been forced
to prioritize some missions over others,
which has led to delays in data
for some lower priority missions.
This happened during Artemis I in 2022.
- [Crew] Lift off of Artemis I.
- [Narrator] Though it
was an uncrewed mission,
NASA prioritized its access to the network
because it's preparing the agency
to send humans to the moon
for the first time in over 50 years.
- We tracked Artemis I
like we will track it
when it has humans on board.
We definitely do not
wanna lose communication
with astronauts, right?
- [Narrator] As a result,
all other missions that use the network
lost over 1,500 hours
of data collection time
during that period.
For example, the James Webb
telescope lost about 185 hours
of data transmission time
when it normally would've been able
to immediately send images back to Earth.
Even though James Webb
and the other missions
were able to eventually
make up for that lost time,
Smith says these delays
could turn into losses
in important data
if nothing is done to increase
capacity on the network.
Baldwin says he's especially concerned
given the ambitious goals
the agency has for Artemis.
- The human landing, the Gateway system,
the commercial landers.
It's gonna be challenging
to meet all the objectives
of all the things we wanna do,
including science and the
human aspiration portion of it.
- [Narrator] The DSN will
face an even greater strain
when the network's largest capacity users
will be in the same part of the sky
vying for the same antennas.
- It's very possible
James Webb will take a hit
on their science data collection.
The Europa Clipper
as we build up the Artemis III and beyond.
The Psyche Mission that just launched.
Really it's users that
require a lot of DSN time
that takes the most amount of impacts.
- [Narrator] So why is the
DSN in this dire state?
One reason is that a lot of missions
are lasting much longer
than originally anticipated.
Voyager, which launched in 1977,
is still transmitting data
from beyond the solar system.
- It is still going strong 46 years later.
Our mission load just keeps growing
'cause we've got all the new missions
and then we also have older missions
that continue to operate.
- [Narrator] But the big reason
is that the DSN's infrastructure,
some of which was built in the sixties,
has become increasingly
difficult and costly to maintain.
- And that cost does increase.
We have inflation, supply
chain issues that impact us.
And so there's a list of things
that will impact our ability
to move out on these antenna builds
and also to maintain our
operational readiness
to support these missions.
- [Narrator] Some major upgrades
also take antennas offline
for months at a time,
which can increase pressure
on the already overburdened network.
- We've had issues of
complexes going down.
That happened on Artemis.
We had a complex go down
and we had to bring back up.
We've had axles break in our antennas.
- [Narrator] The agency
has also had difficulty
building new infrastructure.
Its 2010 initiative to
build six new antennas
is nearly five years behind schedule.
- When we're talking about
long term, it's challenging.
There'll need to be investment
to ensure that we can support
the long-term plans of NASA.
- [Narrator] One potential fix:
a network of smaller antennas
to specifically serve lunar missions
so it can offload those
missions from the DSN.
The first of these antennas
is set to be built by 2026.
NASA is also testing the use
of optical communication or lasers
on the spacecraft studying
the Psyche asteroid.
- Psyche has a tech demo on it right now.
So instead of sending
radio frequency signals
through an antenna,
it will use a laser to encode data.
- Baldwin says the DSN is also leaning
on other space agencies around the world,
borrowing their antenna
networks when needed.
- They did help us with Artemis I.
When we had to shift some of the missions
over to other international agencies,
we did that.
We are gonna explore that for
Artemis II and beyond as well.
- [Narrator] Despite these efforts,
Baldwin says the DSN isn't
out of the woods yet.
- We're concerned, right?
Maintaining schedule is key
and difficult with some
uncertainty in the budget.
So I'd be remiss to say
that there's no worry,
that we're all good.
- For the first time in 50 years,
the DSN is gonna be
supporting human space flight,
but we're also supporting
all of these other missions.
So it's a different load on the DSN
than what we've had recently.
- For the public to know that
we are being good stewards
of taxpayer dollars
and ensuring that we can
bring down that investment
that they made into the science
exploration, I think is key.
(bright music)